tout simplement et je le demande depuis
le mois de janvier
vous savez qu'au mois de janvier le
prison un public a décidé la mise en
place d'une charte de l'islam de france
trois fédérations ont refusé depuis le
mois de janvier de signer cette charte
dont la fédération que vous venez de
citer
eh bien je demande l'exclusion de cette
fédération des entités officielle de
l'islam de france et je demande sa
dissolution à partir du moment où une
association qui prône l'islam politique
ce qui veut dire le refus de la liberté
de culte de conscience de le droit de
changer de religion l'égalité entre les
hommes et les femmes
cette association n'a plus le droit de
cité dans notre pays